South Carolina senator Tim Scott is
calling on the Trump administration to
monitor the impact of the corona virus
on communities of color he is also the
author of the new book opportunity
knocks which chronicles his childhood
struggles in poverty and shows us how we
can use small failures as teaching tools
first on CBS this morning
Senator Scott joins us from outside
Charleston senator good morning thanks
so much for being with us
good morning it's good to be with you I
hope you're well I want to get to the
book in a moment but first as we
mentioned you've spoken directly with
the administration about the need for
better outreach with minority
communities about the corona virus what
exactly would you like to see happen
there I think it's really important for
us to use all resources at our disposal
to make sure that churches small
businesses community centers are all
engaged in this fight to reduce the
spread of the corona virus across
America certainly specifically in the
african-american community
african-americans represent about one
third of all hospitalizations but only
about 13% of the nation's population and
you'll find on most of the front lines
and the grocery stores some of the
takeout services you'll see a lot of
African Americans working and so what we
want to make sure that we understand is
if you have a higher incidence of high
blood pressure and asthma it's really
important for you to take the necessary
precautions from wearing masks washing
hands all the protocols but this is
uniquely and specifically targeting the
African American community with a
strategy to make sure that we are fully
prepared and undertaking those protocols
that will save more more lives than we
have today because what we're seeing in
states like South Carolina 36% 37% of
those folks infected with a corona virus
with a population of only 27% in
Michigan 41% of the fatalities 14% of
the population in Louisiana 70% of the
fatalities and only fewer less than 30%
of the population that they're about in
Mississippi over half
those infected and about 31% of the
population they're about so we're seeing
a higher incidence and I think we can
reduce that or flatten the curve in the
african-american community and it will
help the nation as a whole only a
handful of states actually collect data
on these racial disparities what do you
think a federal tracking system might do
to help doctors well aggregating the
information from the federal level will
be very helpful we're doing in South
Carolina I spoke with my governor he's
on on the game he's on spot that data
would help us to provide the type of
information so that our health care
workers are as protected as possible my
mother spent over forty five years as a
nurse's aide in a hospital so making
sure that the frontline folks are taken
care of is really important one of the
challenges that we have going forward is
if we can if we don't reduce the
incidence of kovat 19 with among our
healthcare workers then who's going to
take care of us so the most important
thing we can do is protect that
frontline by putting a shield between
them and their patients the fastest way
to do that is to have fewer patients the
way you do that is by following the
protocols and the masks are very
important I talk to dr. Fauci about that
specifically a couple of weeks ago and
he said without question masks help you
not spread to your loved ones so when
you're talking with your grandmother or
when you're visiting your your father
helps senator we're all getting the
message about the mask I think so the
president is now poised we opened the
country by May first good morning good
to see you
the president's you know as well reopen
the country on May 1st
dr. Fauci has said listen we're on the
viruses timeline not the other way
around
and it seems like health experts don't
believe that this is the right move I'm
wondering what you're seeing in your
state of South Carolina does it seem
like the right move to you to open May
1st well what I've seen is a lot of
flexibility from the administration as
it relates to what that date was the
date was April 15th but the experts said
that was tube that was premature we saw
a kick to April 30th and as the
information continues to be collected I
think
you'll see perhaps another shift if
necessary in South Carolina we've had
around 80 deaths 2500 plus infection so
I think we are handling it pretty well
we have some hot spots that we're
concerned with but here's what we have
to do the containment strategy was
effective the mitigation strategy is now
flattening the curve but for us to go
back to work and for parents to send
their kids back to schools we're gonna
need an abundance of testing the finger
prick test in my opinion is what we
should be focused on is making sure that
we know who's had it and also being able
to have tests on demand as we enter into
that market you'll see more energy
towards opening this country's economy
back up but without that kind of
certainty
I think everyone's gonna be challenged
as we head into the end of April saying
what we should do without an abundance
of testing especially the test that
tells us who's had it senator in your
book you write about growing up in
poverty and your journey to becoming a
senator
well what advice would you have for
anybody right now for anyone who's
struggling out there you know hope
springs eternal one of the lessons of
the book that you'll learn an
opportunity knocks is I've had health
care challenges I've unfortunately fell
asleep driving a car down the interstate
at 70 miles an hour and went through the
windshield broke my ankle ruined my
senior football season but I found faith
as a result of that I failed in business
and then I found success after that I've
lost campaigns but even in the aftermath
of the campaign losses opportunity
knocked again and I had an opportunity
to to get back in politics and to
finally become a United States Senate I
have had failure failure failure and it
always seems that there's a silver
lining the success follows failure like
that night follows day it's been a
blessing and I hope my story provides
hope during these challenging times
because the one thing I'm completely
confident of is the best is yet to come
for this nation and for most of us in
this nation we have very bright futures
to look forward to I hope we do senator
Scott thank you so much opportunity
knocks is on sale tomorrow